fiscal Committee of the general court
for August 11th is called to order
first item on the agenda is acceptance
of the minutes of June 24th
seconds
further discussion seeing none
all in favor say aye aye any opposed say
no
what's that I explained I was not here
at that meeting very good
two abstentions it passes
okay is there any old business I don't
believe so
and by the way the consent calendar
covers Tab 3 4
and I don't believe we had any requests
to remove anything from consent from the
house meeting anything from the Senate
meeting
nothing to be removed remove the consent
second all right move to pass the
consent calendar and there's a second
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say aye aye opposed no
consent calendar is adopted so we'll
move on to the regular calendar under
all right
first item on Tab 8. is
Department of Justice 23 205 the
litigation expenses and we have John
Broderick here as the administrator who
could answer any questions
Sir Mr chair if I could uh attorney
general for mellers here for uh 23 205.
and then Justice Broderick is here for
the next item all right very good
well good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee uh John fermella attorney
general I'm joined up here by Kathy Carr
our director of administration and I
think the first item that is is ours is
the litigation fund request which I
could give a quick overview of I'm also
happy to answer questions regarding um
the submission from the administrator
but the on the YDC claims fund but he is
here as well so I certainly would not
want to want to preempt him but to the
extent you have questions for me on that
topic I'm absolutely happy to answer
them
on the litigation fund request the
letter summarizes it but this this is
the request that we come to fiscal for
every year for our litigation fund our
litigation fund supplements uh the
Departments the resources the department
has for defending the state and civil
claims Prosecuting criminal cases
consumer protection cases Environmental
Protection cases and really everything
we do
this request this year's for about 6.9
million dollars
it is a high request in the context of
the whole history of litigation fund it
is less than we requested last year I
think last year we requested about 7.8
million dollars if I have that right of
it was around that
so we do have we do have a decrease
um as I note in the in the item the
department continues to deal with the
particularly High load of complex civil
litigation and that really
comes primarily from the from the YDC
litigation you'll note in the letter
we're requesting 2.9 Million Dollars to
assist with that there's a couple of
components when it comes to that one is
defending against the now I think it's
over 1 000 claims against the state that
are in litigation it's one case because
they're all Consolidated but it's really
a thousand different cases so there's
that component of it there's also
assisting the Department of Health and
Human Services with responding to the
criminal justice Bureau and the criminal
investigation so that is also a function
of the Civil Bureau so those two
components combined
necessitate at least by my estimate here
at the beginning of the fiscal year
about 2.9 Million Dollars this coming
fiscal year and a lot of that is review
of documents and responding to discover
requests requests responding to
subpoenas
one thing we do very well in this state
is retain documents for a long time and
so when you end up with something like
this where you are investigating a
series of events that played out over
decades that involves reviewing a lot of
documents and that is a large part of
the cost here
so um there's also
the criminal investigation for YDC
you'll see that request is for about 1.1
million dollars that is less than last
year we have been able to continue to
dedicate internal resources and move
these cases along to a point where we do
estimate spending less this coming
fiscal year but we estimate about 1.1
million dollars there as compared to
about 2.2 million dollars last fiscal
year
and then
for the the remaining large items are
the two cases that I note in here for
the Department of Health and Human
Services one case deals with a
with the challenge to how the department
is administering its choices for
Independence program and another case is
um
are claims uh based on how
how we
um
we serve disabled youth in foster care
those two cases together we estimate a
need of about 1.5 million dollars and
there's a couple of reasons for the for
the major needs there one those are
those are major federal court cases
they're class actions they involve a lot
of documents a lot of document review
they also involved some specialized
areas of law which
the good thing is the department is is I
think we are strengthening our our
expertise in that area because of these
cases but they are they are new types of
litigation that the department is
dealing with that we really have not
dealt with before so we're also using
some outside Council support for those
cases
the remaining request is just for
the the wide variety of other cases the
department deals with that involves
a larger number of cases for much
smaller amounts across the criminal
justice Bureau across the Environmental
Protection Bureau across the consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau all of
that adds up to about the 6.9 million
dollars so that that's an overview and
I'm happy to take any questions
regarding this request
questions for the attorney generals
Senator bird sells seconds
uh further discussion
Senator Rosenwald thank you I did have a
couple of questions if I could
so that 2.9 Million dollars that are
incurring for the YDC
assault cases is
you in a different fiscal item I think
your reporting costs of 340
charged against the fund
um I'm not sure how you
decide what goes to the fund and what
goes to the general funds but so we're
we're talking about 3.2
million dollars of cost
relative to about 4.9 million dollars of
settlements
from the fund it is that a particularly
High proportion of cost
relative to settlement
yeah thank you for the question Senator
because I think it it provides a good
opportunity for me to to clarify a
couple things
with YDC we have we have one
um one part of the office the civil
litigation Bureau is handling the
litigation so the case is in court we've
split off the the AG designee function
under the settlement fund and so the as
you know the expense the funds we're
requesting today are for expenses
related to the litigation the funds
you're noting of about three hundred
thousand dollars under the settlement
fund those are
expenses incurred by us utilizing
outside counsel for some assistance with
reviewing and analyzing claims that are
that are submitted to the claims fund
and those expenses are billed to the
fund
with regard to your question about
whether the the costs of say 2.9 Million
dollars plus 350 000 equaling 3.2
million dollars in in expenses compared
to roughly 4.9 million dollars in
settlement
I would just note that I think by the
time we get to the end of the fiscal
year
I don't think that that will be an
unusually high number because while
while we are at around 4.9 million
dollars in subtle cases right now
the process is really
I think just starting to get going it's
taken us a couple quarters I think to
really get up and running I don't want
to speak for the administrator and but
they've had to get their infrastructure
up and running we have close to 100
claims submitted now I expect by the end
of this fiscal year we are going to have
far more than 4.9 million dollars worth
of settlements and our 2.9 Million
Dollar request is ju is for this fiscal
year so through next June so I expect by
the time we get to next June
that that's going to be a much more
reasonable proportion uh because the 2.9
Million Dollars I'm requesting today we
haven't incurred that to date that's
just what we expect to incur
by the end of the fiscal year through
today
I would say we've incurred maybe a
couple hundred thousand dollars in
expenses for YDC so far this fiscal year
I just expect that by the time we get to
the end we'll be at 2.9 Million and does
that answer your question I apologize if
follow-up question thank you
the um
Amanda D at all versus Hassan
are they is there ongoing monitoring of
this I mean wasn't that a five-year
settlement that should have been
in our Rear View Mirror by now what when
are we going to get out of that so we
certainly were when we entered into that
settlement agreement hoping that all of
our obligations would be complete within
five years we continue to work towards
complying with all of the conditions in
that settlement agreement we engage
a lot with the plaintiffs in that case
frankly we just we still have work to do
work we're close but we continue to have
work to do and so until we have finally
achieved what we set out to under that
settlement agreement there work there
will continue to be monitoring there
will continue to be expenses associated
um
with the Community Mental Health
agreement I think covet has had
something to do with that so we were
already I think gonna go somewhat Beyond
five years covid has continued to impact
that but to answer your question yes the
original intent was to have wrapped that
up after five years
we just aren't there as a state I think
we continue to make progress and
hopefully we will wrap that up in the
coming years but we have not yet but we
continue to work on it we continue to
engage with with plaintiffs and I I
don't want to speak for the plaintiffs
in that case and plaintiff's council
because they're not here today but
I think
I'm safe in saying everybody would agree
that we have good dialogue and we're all
continuing to work together to get to
Senator D'Alessandro and then
representative Edwards uh thank you
thank you Mr stupid I thank you attorney
general attorney general could you tell
me in reading of a report that I got
from the LBA I I felt a little difficult
to uh to figure out but how many cases
has has have you settled that that'd be
the Department of Justice versus how
many cases has the administrative
settled and what's the what's the dollar
amount that's been pushed out the door
as we speak in terms of settled clips
so we have settled I believe nine cases
total because we had one in the first
quarter we had we had eight in the
second
we've had the first proceeding in front
of the administrator so I expect we'll
get a decision from the administrator at
that point
um the way it's set up is that if we can
reach a settlement with the claimant
without needing to go to the
administrator then then we settle the
case if we don't reach an agreement
claims will go for an administrative
proceeding I don't know exactly how many
proceedings have been scheduled now but
there's a number of proceedings that
have been scheduled so we've settled
nine I don't believe we have not had any
resolutions decided by the administrator
but I expect we'll start to see those in
quarter three
and about
I think the the settlement amount total
is about 4.8 4.9 million dollars
of that I think 2.9 has gone out 2.9
Million has actually gone out the door
but the remaining amount is just still
being processed further questions
thank you
what has it cost us in order to do this
I mean I noticed that the 350 000 was
was a cost that you have you have
determined comes out of the fund and the
administrator has costs that come out of
the fund
so that is outlined in the
administrator's report we have had about
we expect we've incurred about 350
and again I don't want to speak for the
administrator but let me see if I can
several hundred thousand I think would
be I think I'm accurate if I say that
it's several hundred thousand so
out of
you know 4.9 million dollars in
settlements we have I mean it's less
than a million dollars in expenses it's
it's
um well under a million dollars and I
expect that that Gap will continue to
grow as because we've had some startup
costs to get the fund going
for the Christmas Jim follow-up so in
terms of time constraints you know the
the time is is passing rather quickly
and the time left is really quite
dividibous when you think of it right we
have about a year
left it to settle all of these cases
there's there's a year a year and a half
closer to the the deadline is December
31st 2024 but
um yeah we're certainly cognizant of
that that time is precious and and like
I said I think it's it's taken some time
for us to get it up and running we've
had good conversations with the
administrator we continue to refine
things he'll have they'll have some
things to present to you today
um close to 100 claims have been
submitted and I think that as we get
further into the two-year period we can
I think we're probably a little too
early to know whether we're behind
schedule or ahead of schedule
it wouldn't last question follow-up and
and how many how many of these cases are
are choosing the other methodology Court
at this point in time so right now we
and this requires a little parsing there
there is a cons there's a consult
they're all Consolidated there's over a
thousand cases right over a thousand
cases have been filed in the
Consolidated litigation now some of
those cases are not cases that we would
think of as YDC cases because judge
showman decided to include cases that
don't involve claims from events that
happened in YDC but involve claims for
individuals who are
um alleging abuse while they were in
foster care and some other placement
but right now in in that Consolidated
Consolidated litigation there's over a
thousand cases
probably at least a couple hundred if
not more of those are not what I would
call YDC cases so to answer your
question right now we have about 100
claims submitted in the claim fund
there are you know probably seven seven
hundred or so
that's just a very rough estimate that
are in court there's some overlap
between those because you can file a kit
you can bring a lawsuit and then stay it
while you try the claims fund but I
think to answer your question we have
about 100 claims in the claims fund
they're about 700 700 to 800 YDC cases
in court
of course our hope is that we we
continue to have that the court number
go down and the claims number fund
number go up I think will still remains
to be seen the progress we can make with
that but we I would say I'm I'm
optimistic at this point but we have
work to do that that's for sure
thank you thank you thank you Mr chip
representative Edwards for a question uh
thank you Mr chair uh good seeing you um
Mr attorney general I say um i i i the
way this law got put together the AG's
office did great work in drafting
something that was brought to the
legislature the legislature then in a in
a committee process worked with you to
improve upon it and tweak it or at least
we thought we were improving upon it so
so now that we've we've tried this new
law that was unique in the nation
uh are are there things that you're
seeing that might cause us to want to go
back and tweak the litigation to because
we've learned something we're smarter
than what we were now I I don't think we
want to change the rules of the game now
that it's gotten started and we take
something fairly powerful but are you
are you are you seeing the law as being
um pretty stable pretty good or did did
we miss something we need to come back
and try to fix
appreciate the question representative
and I know the the administrator will
have thoughts on this too I think
I think it's been pretty good we did
have a couple of changes that the
administrator suggested in the last
session that we thought were good ones
and and that the legislature made
regarding changing some terminology and
and
um
and moving the waiver to the end of the
process I think that we're likely to
identify additional tweaks that might be
good ideas as we sit here today I think
it's working pretty well the
administrator has a couple of
suggestions in his letter that we'll
talk we expect to talk more about with
with him not the changes that are
actually before you today but he has a
couple of additional observations that
we expect we'll talk with the
administrator and his team about and
you know we probably as we go now into
quarter three and quarter four
I wouldn't be surprised if we identify
additional changes that might be a good
idea say going into the 2024 session but
I but overall I would answer a question
to say I think it's working pretty well
but I think now that we have a hundred
claims in
over the next few months we're going to
get
better a better set of data to evaluate
you know what what additional changes
might might be a good idea
I read in the administrators report that
The Proposal so far could represent 82
million dollars
and
I'm concerned with months to go more
more and more people coming in
um
about whether we exceed that 100 million
now you have the options I guess
some of this money is if there's a
payout it might go over 10 years right
so we don't spend all this money up
front in the first biennium that's a
potential option but that comes down to
an election by the claimant so it's it's
difficult to predict what portion of
that might get paid out over time or
what portion might be paid out in a lump
sum I thought it was traditional that
you just don't pay it all out at once
no it it's an option but and we I
remember we had this discussion during
the legislative process we ultimately
decided at least for now you know in
this this iteration of the process to
have it be the option of of the claimant
we've only had again we've only had nine
settlements and so we don't I don't
think we have enough of a data set right
now to predict what percentage will get
paid out over time but to your point Mr
chairman about the 82 million total
requests
that's what's requested I can tell you
so far our experience has been is that
we're often settling or paying out
amounts that are below the initial
request and so again I think
we'll have better data in a few months
to tell you you know what we're on track
for but the total amount requested
is not not necessarily a good barometer
of the total amount that will be paid
out on those on those claims
because of the nature of of the crimes
it's likely to be no Witnesses nothing
written down didn't tell people
kept its secret private whatever so
and we're using lie detector on any of
these people that you know it comes in
otherwise it's nothing supported but
your word
so is that become a routine to use a lie
detector otherwise we have we don't have
corroboration
we certainly we wouldn't use a a
polygraph or any type of lie detector
test
we really try to treat each claim in
each individual as
as a as its own claim its own set of
facts its own set of circumstances
some claimants in working with their
attorneys will will submit a a
investigator report because they will
have it voluntarily sat down with an
investigator and they'll tell us about
that investigator and so that we can
assess their reputation some claimants
may take a different approach
ultimately if if we can't reach a
resolution it will go to a proceeding in
front of the administrator and the
administrator and his team and again I
don't want to speak for them but they've
put a lot of thought and work into how
they're going to handle the
administrative uh the any administrative
proceeding but we we wouldn't use a
polygraph or a lie detector test but I
think we're all putting a lot of thought
into for any individual claim you know
how do we how do we assess it and it's
difficult to paint you know to really
use any broad brush with which to paint
these claims because I you know I can't
get any into any specific claim of
course but I can tell you based on what
I've seen
there you know there are different
circumstances and different facts that
go with with each of these claims in
each of these individuals these claims
span decades there's going to be
differences in what records are
available and differences in what
corroboration there might be as far as
who we could who we could even hope to
to talk to given that these events
happen happened decades ago so
um that's I think the best I can tell
you is we we have put a lot of thought
and I know the administrator and his
team have put a lot of thought into the
need to balance the need to assess these
claims objectively while respecting the
individual victims that that bring
forward these claims and that really
requires uh a determination on a
case-by-case basis as to what type of
verification methods we're going to
undertake do we even have the capability
given a date
to find out if that person was in fact
incarcerated in one of those
institutions and if a employee is named
to find out if that employee was
employed in that institution do we have
that record that we can at least verify
those things yes we generally do have
records to verify that that a um a
claimant would have been a resident at
YDC at the time and that if a
perpetrator is named they would have
been employed at the time is important
to remember that sometimes if someone
was 13 12 13 years old and they were a
victim and it's decades ago they may not
remember a name they may be able to
describe the person they may not have
memory of a name
thank you
General there was one claim that was
settled for the max of the 1.5 million
my question is there seems to be a a
difference of opinion between those
representing the claimant uh
is that is that still in the litigation
or what's the story though or has a has
the Cleveland paid to to the individual
that's the first question and secondly
the the two parties that are involved
the original group of lawyers that
represented him versus the settlement
what's the story how how is that uh
how's that handled
so I believe that claim has been paid as
you know there is a dispute between
between attorneys involved over over
um entitlement to fees yes that
that is uh that is litigation that's
going to play out between the parties
the the parties the attorneys in in the
case I believe there's a court I believe
they have a court date scheduled for
later in August they have a hearing but
um that's really not something we will
involve ourselves in good food that's
that's really what I wanted to do we
would have no involvement at this point
in time the claim has been settled
everything else is the responsibility of
the parties involved correct okay thank
you thank you Mr chairman
anything further for the Attorney
General
we'll ask administrative Roderick to add
any cogent information and some of you
may have questions for him thank you
Mr chairman if I could there's a pending
motion to adopt the litigation portion
uh Senator gray and Senator bird cell
that's 23205. yeah I understand that it
just I guess
the uh the piece that the administrator
would comment is over and above that so
all right
we do have a motion in a second so any
further discussion on that specific
motion to give them the litigation
expenses requested
seeing none all in favor say aye aye
opposed no that motion is adopted
administrator if you would like to make
any further comments on these litigation
expenses we will come later to an item
that you have that we may have further
[Music]
Mr chairman and members of the committee
uh would it be appropriate for me to say
five minutes and give you an overview of
where I see things
yes it would now first of all I I want
to say at the outset that
the attorney general and the Attorney
General's office has been
collaborative and cooperative
I'm an independent operation as the
statute defines and I am independent
my assessment of where we are now
is this legislature in my view
did exactly the right thing when you
establish this fund
I've been doing this work now for eight
months
and over that time I've had a chance to
read a number of files that have come
into our office and are transported the
Attorney General's office
those files are confidential
the impact those files make on you
is significant
I think it's important people understand
that
most of the people coming into the
system are over 50 years of age what
happened to them happened 30 plus years
ago sometimes longer
they were kids
and their memories are not
photographic nor should they expect it
the Attorney General's office has been
handling these claims
and until my office thanks to an
amendment here
allowed the administrator
to hold a hearing without requiring
people to waive their rights against the
state
once that happened we're starting to see
more requests
for de novo review not that the Attorney
General's den of review was incorrect
I'm not saying that but they want to
give it one more bite of the apple with
my office
and so we are at the front of that right
now
and so I appreciate the fact the
legislature made that change
but let me give you some Global issues
that I think all of us need to focus on
doesn't mean we need to change but I
think we need to acknowledge it
under the statute my office
is not allowed to accept any claims from
any person
the window closes we can process claims
that have been submitted before them but
we can't take new claims
the first trial to my knowledge is
scheduled in the Superior Court
by a YDC claimant will be April of 2024.
I don't know how the court system is
going to deal with that
I read recently the Court's thinking
maybe they can bundle these cases 10 at
a time
I'm not casting a judgment on that I
think that would be difficult
in any event by the end of December of
next year
the 800 or 1000 cases the Attorney
General mentioned to you
will not have been resolved in the
unless those folks file those cases also
in our administrative process
once the end of December next year comes
they'll have only one option which is to
go to court
the purpose I think of what the
legislature did not commend it is to see
whether or not a confidential process
not a jury trial I'm familiar with those
a confidential process it's trauma
informed
and victim-centered would attract people
to come in
I think it's attracting people to come
maybe not at the pace we all hope
but I do think the pace will increase
will it increase by the end of next year
to Encompass almost all of those
thousand cases I think the jury is still
and so I think it's important that
we look at what's happening we determine
if we're okay with that
or whether any changes need to be made
to hasten the migration of cases from
the spiritual docket
to this process
that is a policy question way above my
pay grade
but it is a policy question that's
appropriate for this committee
and what might be done
to change the rate at which cases are
migrating and right now most of the
cases we're receiving by the way
are not in the Superior Court
they're coming in from other sources
most of them have lawyers not all of
them
but there is a reluctance I think
to come into the system at the level
that all of us think maybe would be
appropriate
and so we are designing so you
understand we're designing our operation
to accommodate all of those cases I I
can't prepare for the flood after the
the water is rising
so we are preparing for success
whether or not we're over preparing
remains to be seen but I can't do it at
the last minute
um
we had our first hearing as an
administrator a de novo hearing with a
claimant
within the last 10 days
I had two meetings today with claimants
and their Council and the Attorney
General's office so it's good to see
that's happening
but if it continues at that pace
in a year and a half I'll be saying well
we we tried but we didn't get there
uh and again that's not my call
but I I will say this to you in the
cases that I've read and I've read a
number of them who've come to us
it's pretty disturbing what I'm reading
and I remind myself all the time these
are children
these are children who had nothing to do
with the physical or sexual abuse I'm
reading about
I also know and believe that it's
probably not in their interest these
kids now full adults
to wait three or four years longer
to walk into a Superior Courthouse
and take an oath and testify in front of
jurors
we have designed this process as I think
you intended
it doesn't look like a superior court
case it doesn't feel like a spiritual
case and I am not acting like a judge
I'm the administrator I have only the
authority you give me
but one thing we did do we went out and
retained on a Consulting basis
some trauma-informed folks
one individual worked for years with the
police department investigating sexual
and physical abuse claims she's
extraordinary
and we have another person who all of
you would know who's also on that same
page
and when we had the first hearing
couple weeks ago now the questioning was
done through that person of the claimant
not by me
when she finished I had a few questions
I asked them
the Attorney General's office to their
credit
and the claimants Council to their
credits and we don't need to be in the
room we'll be in another room
and you'll show it to us on video but
we're not going to be in the room and
they've been very willing to let me or
my expert
trauma-informed expert ask the questions
it becomes like a conversation it's not
a deposition
so the system that you've designed I
think you designed it beautifully I
commence you for it I mean that
whether its current configuration
and resources are adequate for what you
hope to accomplish
I have some thoughts on that
but
again it's not my call
but to the extent that the system is up
and running the Attorney General's
office is trying to level best I I
believe they are I believe my office is
doing the level best sitting to my right
is John Foley
who had the misfortune apparently of
clerking for me for a decade when I was
on the Supreme Court so she's the bright
one
but anyway I was able to get her out of
a very secure job
there's no small task to come and serve
as general counsel
we have two paralegals in our office
to help us process
we need to have technology to do the job
well
we now have about 125 filings as opposed
to 92
and maybe by the end of this quarter
we'll have 150.
the last thing I want to mention and I
don't know whether will happen or not
but I practice law for a lot of years so
I know what I would have done
all these cases that are in the Superior
Court
if if counsel for those claimants
decides December 31st next year not to
file anything with us
the only route those claimants will have
is a jury trial
maybe two years hence maybe three years
hence
a jury trial having tried many of them
myself is a very different experience
you're not going to have a
trauma-informed expert ask you the
questions
My Hope Is I don't want to say
expectation but my hope is
that before December 31 2024
a lot of those cases currently on the
docket in the Superior Court while
they'll still remain there
will also file a claim with us
because there's no downside to filing a
claim unless there's no Prejudice thanks
to your amendment I can get involved and
get my uniform dirty if they don't like
what I say they can stay in court
if that happens
we're going to have to process those
claims
because of the people filing them with
us will be a year or two or longer away
from a jury trial
and we don't take a year or two to get
the claim to the point where we're ready
that would be an enormous undertaking
we're preparing for that I'm not
complaining we're preparing for it
because I think it's wise to assume that
if this legislature wanted to ensure
that more claims would file more quickly
and be happy to be in our system
I think there are some changes that
could be made again not my call so we
are doing our level best I can assure
you
with our staffing with our trauma
informed experts the Attorney General's
office has been very competent and very
cooperative
and so I'm optimistic about where we are
but I'm not overly optimistic about
whether people are going to come see us
because the window is closing
or whether they're going to come see us
because they think they should
thank you administrative questions from
the committee
representative Edwards uh thank you for
stepping forward into this critical role
it's thank you very much I you've you've
left me wanting to to know the rest of
the story you're saying you have things
that you think we ought to be doing to
modify the the existing law to help us
move these cases to you but you're not
enumerating them with us today so that's
fine I I'm just I just would like to
know what process you or the Attorney
General are using to work with the mem a
member of the legislature to begin
consideration of these changes
I'm a process guy I want to make sure
you got a process the process as
designed is fine
uh it's not going to be the process that
my sense is this
a lot of the claims that are out there
would be very appropriately handled in
the process you've designed with the
capture put in place
I think that's true
but it's not going to apply to every
case that's out there
and the question I would have were I a
policy maker
is what is the overall goal here
is the goal to have some of these cases
migrate to this process and then close
the window and try all the rest
where's the goal to get as many of those
cases possible to migrate to this
process so that what's left is not going
to be great
I was a trial lawyer for 22 years so I
know what trying cases feels like I know
how expensive it is
and the Attorney General's officers have
said is
highly competent so I know that too
but it's going to be expensive it's
going to be expensive think about trying
800 or a thousand cases to a jury
I'm not the chief justice but I would
lie a weeknights wondering how it's
going to accommodate that onslaught
if I were the Attorney General's office
I'd say how can we try 800 cases
if I were the plaintiff's council the
claimants challenge so I'd say how are
we going to do that
how are we going to be standing when
it's over
and at the end of the day
as those calculations be made
the whole purpose of the funds you
created was to help these kids now
adults who through no fault of their own
were sexually and physically abused
so if I were
suggesting a change may be premature but
I don't think so
if you look at the amount of the claims
file the gross amount that's being
sought already for 92 claims
it's 82 million dollars
you can do the math on the dancer Clans
I'm not saying it's worth 82 million
the attorney general has settled I think
eight cases we're not involved
they said late cases I think for 4.8
million dollars
so it's not as if trying these cases in
the superior court it's going to be less
expensive or get you a result that may
cost the state less
so if I were looking at this
holistically again I'm at the front end
of it
I would think maybe
100 million dollars is not going to do
it
maybe we need to look at that
maybe in extreme circumstances not the
average circumstance as bad as they are
I might look at the caps and say in
exceptional circumstances the Attorney
General's office in the first instance
would have the capacity to go up to this
number for a cap
and if it doesn't end there they can
come see me but I can't go about that
cap either those would be for the
exceptional circumstances as defined by
this legislature
for a lot of the cases
the Caps I think
are fair
I mean whether they're appropriate I
don't know but they're reasonable I
don't know how to compensate someone for
that but you've got to pick a number
somewhere and I think this legislature
to this level best to do that I applaud
you for it
but if you want more cases to come
you've got to raise the caps on the on
the most extreme cases and I honestly
believe
not today but you need to consider
putting more money in that fund
the money that you put in the plan isn't
being spent unless people come to seek
it
but it will be spent if the Attorney
General of this state and his office has
to prepare and try
hundreds and hundreds of cases
and it will cost that you cherish some
money too that that's not in their
budget and that's my guess
so I I think those changes would be
helpful
and I think it would matter and the
question I think is not whether
more money would help
but when you decide it should be
allocated
I'm not saying today you need to do it
but when you look at the math and the
quarter two report
you look at the cases the attorney
general has settled
I think you can see that you're quickly
going to get to a number that
probably won't do it
thank you that's what I think
Senator gray for a question
uh actually it's not a question it's a
suggestion to you Mr chair most of this
conversation we've had is probably more
appropriate for the last item in tab 13
which is the informational item right
now I'm respecting the rest of the
people that are here in their time I
would like to go back to tab nine and
move
um
247 which is the uh adjustment or or the
claims process for the administrative
settlement the updates that were
provided to us and I believe that those
are appropriate and should be adopted
that is the item nine and you might add
to your emotion that any future
Corrections or to language spelling Etc
be freely made without coming back to us
so if there's anything I certainly would
add that all right so that will be part
of that motion that any further minor
changes can be made at the discretion of
the administrator they don't change the
sum the meaning of what what is in the
piece
further questions
on item nine yes I would second it but I
have a question
motion is made and seconded thank you
sir representative Senator there are a
couple typos
in here all right I can't hear a couple
of typos
in the the 90 Pages the 90 pages that
you sent us but my question is have you
seen the letter with two suggestions
from the association for justice
they made two discrete suggestions one
is that where you say the forms are
developed by the Attorney General
that it would be that we would add with
Consulting the claimants Council
and the second suggestion is that there
be a digital claims packet available
guess I'd like to know what your
um comments on those two suggestions
might be
good
hi so your first the first suggestion
was to make sure that claims council is
consulted uh with respect to forms I
mean we we have done that in terms of I
think by Statute anytime the the
administrator has to uh bring
suggestions that that's something we
bring to both the attorney general and
claims Council so I mean I'm not sure
what the Attorney General would think
about it but we would see that as just
part of built into what is kind of
already already out there in terms of
making sure everybody has an opportunity
to see changes or to see suggestions so
I I don't see an issue with it I don't
know if the Attorney General's office
would
in terms of the second digital claims
packet we've been asked about that um
several times it is something we we want
to do it really is about
um you know the resources that where
we're putting staff resources on what
items we're actually in conversation
with a particular consultant
um with to to maybe go under contracts
to have a much more automated system and
the digital form packet would be a part
of an automated system I think given the
volume that we expect to have we need to
have something that's automated and
those are conversations I've been having
with the attorney general designee as
well and we would definitely involve
claims Council make sure that such a
process an automated process would be
working for everyone not just our staff
yeah I just want to add one thing
we have met on two occasions one in
April and one in June
with all defense Council all climate
Council uh Jennifer Ramsey the Attorney
General's officers Ben the last meeting
we had
was very constructive we had the
trauma-informed people that we've
retained and they were there and present
I think it's been very open I mean I I
don't think any claimant consequence say
to you that these people aren't
listening
and Jennifer Ramsey who is the point
person in that office on this process
has come to those meetings who
participates fully in those meetings uh
I think the Attorney General's office is
interested in suggestions I don't have
any sense or not
so it's uh
it's early people are trying to figure
out who we are what are we really about
so I I think you know we're going to
build that image hopefully it'll be
successful
but I also want to say on this record I
think the Attorney General's office has
been
you're very diligent and thoughtful in
what they're doing
so there's no bad person in the equation
my fear is that
however you define success
what does that look like
and if the window closes on this process
in a year and five months
and 700 cases remain in the Superior
Court
is that why you did this
and if it's not why you did it what
changes can you make now 17 months out
that my my grades Association is far
more quickly that's that's not my call
but I I think how you define success
further discussion from committee
seeing none the question before us is to
approve item nine with the addition to
make any other minor changes that would
be administrative finds necessary
no Mr chair just uh could have been me
you just need a second
sure Mr chair if I may uh Senator gray
made the motion I just want to clarify
who may the second instead of Rosemont
I think he's got it yeah I've got it so
no further discussion are you ready for
the for the question all in favor of of
the motion as as amended say aye aye
opposed no that motion is adopted thank
you thank you folks thanks very much
all right moving on to item 10
and the commissioner has been
waiting patiently
to hear about for us to hear about
good afternoon for the record Frank
gator blue Commissioner of Education
okay
question before us is
the school infrastructure fund
authorization to retroactive amend
FIS 220 22 303 approved September 9
2020. extending the end date from June
30 2023 to June 30 2024. is there a
motion
Senator D'Alessandro moves to accept
seconded by Senator Rosenwald further
discussion
your patience is rewarded all in favor
say aye aye opposed no
motion is adopted
thank you
all right
236.
Office of the governor authorization
authorization to retroactively amend FIS
22 380 approx approved November 18th
2022 as amended by FIS 23164 in May 2023
and extend the end date from June
2023 to June 30 2024.
move to prove motion motion to approve
by Senator gray second by
Senator Bradley is there any further
discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
motion is adopted
all right
foreign
Office of the consumer advocate
and we have someone from The Office of
Consumer Advocate please
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee not only do you have
someone from the office of the consumer
Advocate you have the consumer advocate
for the record my name is Donald crease
and I've served as consumer Advocates
since early 2016. our office represents
the interests of residential utility
customers at the puc just by way of
briefly introducing this item to you
there are currently two major rate cases
pending at the Public Utilities
Commission and I expect as many as one
or two more to be filed next year the
fundamental task in a rate case is for
the puc to decide what the annual
revenue requirement of a utility is
that's basically how much money the
utility should take in in total from all
of its customers the annual revenue
requirement is itself a sum of two
numbers the first number is the
utilities operating costs that's pretty
straightforward the second number is a
return on the company's investment and
we derive that number by taking
basically the present value of all the
capital assets the utility has in
service and we multiply that by the
utilities cost of capital the cost of
capital is a blended average of
basically how much money the utility
owes its lenders because they borrow
about half of their capital resources
from lenders and the other half is a
return on Equity that is basically what
the shareholders of the company are
entitled to earn in exchange for them
having made their investment item number
11 asks your permission to hire an
outside expert to help us argue that the
return on Equity requested by the
utilities is too high this is a very
esoteric specialty I can think of only
three people in the entire State of New
Hampshire who would be qualified to
testify as an expert on this subject one
of them is now a member of the Public
Utilities Commission the second one is
the head of the Department of Energy's
regulatory Support Division and the
third happens to be the president of
Unitil one of our utilities and boy am I
glad he has that job now because he is
out of this game and he was a formidable
expert witness for utilities back when
he was doing that for a living so we put
out an RFP our office is presently
understaffed so we had to put out an RFP
for a variety of forms of assistance in
rape cases and I believe at your next
meeting I'll be back with a different
contract that covers different stuff but
in this instance the expert that we
decided to hire is a gentleman from
Connecticut who submitted a bid to us we
were impressed because of some excellent
work he did on a similar rate case down
in Connecticut so that's the reason I'm
here our statute allows us to supplement
our Resources by a special assessment
but in order to do that we need the
permission of both the governor and
Council and your permission
We snuck into the governor in Council
and got their permission ahead of yours
and now the matter is pending before you
I agree for most true proof second
motion and a second to approve the
request further discussion
seeing none
are you ready for the question all in
favor say aye aye opposed no
the motion is adopted thank you very
much for coming thank you very much
all right moving on to
the information materials
oh the late item thank you very much the
we see before us
um
so who's here from dot I see I think
and the recommendation came down from
the
executive Council to buy rather than
lease so we'll hear about that
thank you commissioner
uh thank you chairman Wyler for
entertaining our our late item um very
brief summary we have um
for the last 10 years we have leased
loaded backhoes to um
uh working our Patrol uh Patrol sections
loading trucks loading salt for the
winter and and uh doing summer work of
um
ditching and Hauling and so forth but um
uh at the last council meeting as we
brought forward this this third
iteration of a five-year lease uh the
executive Council asked us to do an
analysis of uh of buying versus uh
leasing the analysis showed a
substantial savings to the state over
the five years of the lease
and they had uh subsequently uh voted
down the lease item and recommended us
to uh proceed with the with the purchase
to facilitate that purchase we are here
to uh fiscal
um
seeking a transfer from the highway
Surplus account to facilitate that that
purchase so the costs are more than in
our budget for this biennium but over
the five years of the lease and the
analysis is there I can answer any
questions to that there is a
um
substantial savings and overall Savings
of uh about approximately five million
dollars to the state so we'd ask your
entertainment to
um
uh transfer about 4.8 million dollars
from the highway uh from the highway
fund to support the lease I mean support
the purchase at this time
Senator gray move to approve second
Senator gray moves to prove Senator
Bradley seconds further discussion
seeing Nani ready for the question all
in favor say aye aye opposed pose no
that item is adopted thank you for
saving the money thank you God thank you
all very much for taking the late item
we appreciate it
now we'll move on to information
lightings
thanks for the reminder of the late item
anything anybody wishes questions on in
Senator Rosenwald thank you I just I
have a question for commissioner Weaver
if she'll take it okay that'll likely be
on the that would be most relevant to
good afternoon
Lori Weaver commissioner no interim
commissioner
congratulations thank you and Marissa
my question is based on the news story
from the other day about these two
teenage boys
who were placed in residential treatment
in Tennessee and are being
traumatized
um
I guess we can't use the word abused but
the child advocate suggested a month ago
that they'd be brought back to New
Hampshire and so I have a two-part
question one is when are we going to get
these two boys here and two are they
possible
Resonance of the prtf at Hampstead is
that level three is that the right
would that be a placement for them or
where we where are they going to go and
when
sure so I'll take I'll start and if
there's anything you want to add in um I
I'm happy to tell you that as of just a
little while ago we can confirm that
they will both be arriving back in New
Hampshire next week
thank you and they actually will not be
going to the prtf that's a that's a
level five they were currently at a
level four so we have found appropriate
equivalent placement here in New
further questions on the dashboard
seeing none
is there any further questions on the
informational items
seeing none we'll move on to
the next meeting
September 15th is is kind of the
traditional
Friday
is there a problem with the 10 o'clock
Time start
he may tell us about a problem not he is
I've committed to an event
uh at that thing at a local University
so it'll probably take you out for the
whole day oh it starts at eight in the
morning and it goes through the day yes
okay so it doesn't matter when we meet
you won't be here that's correct thank
you Senator rosenmore it's Rosh Hashanah
oh I didn't see that that's probably not
appropriate
all right I didn't have that written
down
it shows up on my calendar
oh no that's that musical band right it
moves around
and it's also Hispanic Heritage Month
begins well
there it is there it is it says Saturday
is the first day of Rosh Hashanah
16.
uh well
okay it's on my calendar for the 15th
President
is Saturday the 16th but you say okay so
then it starts in the evening so in that
case it won't affect us it won't affect
Russia since it's September do it on a
Thursday as opposed to Friday
I don't see a problem
because we won't be we won't be meeting
and it won't be all tied up in meetings
as Mr Kane see a problem
senator
said a request for the 14th yes is there
okay then
Senator representative Edwards uh yes
sir I just want to let you know that due
to uh surgery I I probably will be
unable to make any meeting until
December and so I'll need alternates
very good we always have very many
alternates that attend every meeting and
I'm delighted we have them and then we
always have use for them especially
today
so we will have a we will have an
alternate for
representative Edwards
so
any
thought we were going to get back to
Justice Broderick
well
did you have further questions for him I
did but we can have we can have the LBA
send the questions to him and have them
get back to all of us
um I I think it might be better actually
given
this testimony that we asked him to come
back in September at our September and
the point I was going to make to him was
uh um I'm glad to hear the collaboration
between the Attorney General's office
and the administrator I think that's
exactly what
um
you know representative umberger's Bill
set up a couple of years ago
um the changes he's suggesting the
amount of dollars the egregious cases
limits
um
I think
just just speaking for myself
that those of us that worked on that
piece of legislation and the changes
that were made in hb2 we're going to
want to rely on the experts and I
wanted the attorney general and the
administrator to hear that because I
think the suggestions need to come to us
as opposed to us making the suggestions
to go to them good so
if you could politely ask them to come
back in September I'll reiterate that
I think it did support of of Senator
Bradley I think it was quite clear that
the administrator had some changes that
he thought would be appropriate in order
to expedite the process it the type
constraint is really what we're what
we're dealing with and if something
could be done to expedite that and
expedite more people getting into the
queue I I think that will still have a
problem if I can I'm glad to see that
they're moving on the digital claims uh
anything that simplifies the process is
going to expedite claims coming out of
the court and into the settlement
process so I think that's good and and I
do I'm glad to see that they are
communicating about the consultation
between the council and
um the administrator too so
that's helpful but hopefully we get a
progress report on both of those in
um September yeah obviously there were
changes they're making continuously so
yeah it is good to have them back every
month this week so and if this is going
to go over 100 million dollars we want
to have exactly and we want to rely on
you know the people that have to settle
this for their best
estimates as to what we need to do I I
don't want to be and I don't think any
of us want to be you know blindly going
into the dark where we're talking about
as much resources as this could be so we
allowed we get a lot of questions from
our constituents
I think if we hear about changes in the
process that may expedite the hearings
that may have a positive effect on the
Abode yes you know we wouldn't have to
move the above if indeed these have done
it but I am I am surprised there's no
polygraph when there's no Witnesses no
corroboration of any kind you just tell
a story and you know
well I do have a suggestion
to slightly modify Senator Bradley's
suggestion and that is that I'd like to
see these vetted through the AG's office
when we got these suggestions during the
Senate Finance hearings there were
things that the Attorney General
um
did didn't especially like okay and so
to have that opportunity to have him go
to the attorney general and either
present a combined recommendation or the
recommendation and then the Attorney
General's response I think is going to
be much more helpful to us in trying to
make any decision so just my two cents
in that how that process should work
I was I was I was behind the the ball I
was thinking about the um
lie detector test that's not something
you commonly see in any kind of civil
litigation
besides it would it would it would
violate several several items in the
Constitution if you try to do it that
um all I was going to say is I totally
agree with uh Jim on what he just said
that's why I said the spirit of
collaboration is really good and I would
hope that
Mr Kane in the minutes the this
conversation gets back both to Justice
Broderick and to
um the Attorney General yes I'll craft
an email to them
um I'll also send them the clip from
this meeting but I'll kind of give him
an idea of what the committee is looking
to hear in September had both of them
work together come back with suggested
recommendations since a lot of these are
going to require legislation you're
going to want to have that open
discussion here so you have a chance to
file but I can share that with them yes
yes haven't lost anything on your
fastball
and
when you get a chance some content
contact information since we can't go
over to the corner office and find
anybody there yes there's some wonderful
Renovations going on at the State House
in our office so we are all over the
place we're like the men without
countries so I'm over in the audit but
you can always call my cell phone I'll
send the committee my cell phone you can
call if you email Pam Chris and I we'll
make sure that either we respond to you
by phone or email Harper like
um or um
we can have the analyst reach out to you
also if there's any in-person meetings
like fiscal and things like that we make
sure we're here so but that should be
done knock on wood bye middle September
Labor day or so I think
very good anything further from
committee members
seeing none
I will entertain a motion to adjourn so
moved all in favor
we are adjourned thank you very much Mr
King
Regina